this is the Jocko underground podcast
number 48 sitting here with Echo Charles
and was thinking through sort of let's
call it the lifespan of the podcast that
we do called the Jocko podcast and there
was a while where a little while in the
beginning and someone asked me about
this the other day there's a little
while in the beginning where we were
considering
I was considering instead of doing it
once a week
doing it like once every two weeks maybe
even once a month
and we sort of talked about that we we
kind of broached that topic a little bit
on the podcast itself and I think that
was me kind of trying to socialize that
idea a little bit with the people you
know of saying hey
this is not a real sustainable workload
of the amount of effort that it takes
to put into doing the podcast and by the
way doing this podcast doing the Jocko
podcast and this podcast and the
unraveling podcast
and the warrior kid podcasts like all
these podcasts they're not really my my
primary jobs so there's people that have
a like the primary thing that they do
with their life
is do a podcast but this isn't really oh
like other people who do podcasts other
people that do podcasts like that's what
they do in their life is they do podcast
that's kind of it uh you know which is
cool
this is this is one
portion of what I do and
the so the workload is not like oh one
podcast a week was a lot I don't know if
I can handle it it was at one podcast a
week plus the bunch of other things I
have going on it didn't seem like it was
sustainable and so I was kind of
I was kind of you know socializing the
idea with the people of like hey you
know we're maybe thinking well the
feedback was not good from the people
they were like no hell no uh
the first person I told about it was was
a guy was he was a guy I was working
with through Echelon front and he was
like a big listener to the podcast and I
don't know how deep we were we maybe
were like 50 deep or something like this
but when I started to tell them I was
like Hey we're thinking about going to
once you know once every two weeks maybe
once a month he was like
I don't I don't know if that's a good
idea he was he was saying as if I was
cutting off oxygen to people so that
made me rethink it some of the feedback
we got
but yeah the work the workload is tough
because there's no there's no staff
there's no one like helping to prep
there's no one doing any research or
anything like that
uh and so so that's so so we just kind
of stuck stuck it stuck to it you know
and then
after a little while after like another
probably 50 podcasts
I said to myself that
this the the
discipline that was imposed upon me by
forcing myself to do this thing
was hugely beneficial it was making me
read more it was making me write more it
was making me think through things more
it was making me question myself and
what I knew or what I thought I knew
so
essentially there's a lot of things that
I've thought about and put out that I
never would have put out if I hadn't
been squeezing on my brain to put it out
yeah there's a lot of books that I
wouldn't have read and wouldn't have
known anything about if I wouldn't have
been saying hey I owe a podcast so
therefore I have to read this book
because otherwise maybe I'd be you know
watching uh Netflix
and and you know eating popcorn in front
of the television for four hours but no
I'm reading a book for four hours
what am I doing on a Sunday I'm reading
a book what am I doing on a Saturday
evening I'm reading a book what am I
doing Saturday day I'm reading a book
what am I doing Monday afternoon oh I'm
prepping so
the the the benefit that that's given me
has been great to put myself in a
position where I kind of have to do this
stuff and
I think right now we're gonna keep
pushing
um now we you know explore some other
topics that interest me but yes there
are other there are other topics in the
world that
I'm interested in and that have
influenced me and that I've learned from
besides just War now War obviously is my
primary
mode of thinking is that weird uh well a
little bit weird yeah for the normal
person if I'm gonna if I'm gonna make a
comparison I'm almost always gonna go to
war yeah I'm always almost always going
to think about some kind of War because
the comparison is like okay here's an
example we're gonna we're gonna be able
to see the example very clearly because
it's gonna be a life and death scenario
this is gonna be a pressure leadership
situation like war is good for that and
that's why I kind of think that way but
I also have gotten things from
things that aren't war from other
aspects of life from Jiu Jitsu is
another huge one
but you know from surfing from playing
music from listening to music from
just from other activities and other
things and other people in life that
I've met along the way so
you know
maybe some people be like I don't want
to hear about that stuff and that's okay
right that's okay I understand there's
going to be some people that just want
to hear about war cool that's cool there
might maybe I'll make maybe we'll make
some podcasts that they might not want
to listen to
you know we've had some musicians on
here
we've had a photographer on here
we've had we've we've had business
people on we've so we've had some other
people on the podcast
but
it's okay
because I think if I'm starting to do
something that I'm not or if I if I'm
chasing something that I'm interested in
then I'm happy about it and I pursue it
and I'm gonna I'm gonna learn more and
if I learn something here's the cool
thing just like a book if I pick up a
book to do the podcast on and I get 20
pages into the book and I'm like this is
not gonna get me anywhere it's not gonna
I have nothing to pass on to anybody
from this then I'm not doing it well if
I decide to think about doing a topic
and I decide hey you know what maybe
this isn't like there's nothing to learn
here there's no broad lessons for P for
the people I'm not putting it out
so
yeah I think we just keep driving we
will keep driving down this road we
don't know what's up ahead I
legitimately don't know what's up ahead
as far as topics as far as
like subject matter as far as human
beings that we bring on or that come on
I don't know I don't know where it ends
up
because I'm not I'm not sure where the
road goes but it has been been a long
strange trip this far yeah yeah
I feel like the the good and this is me
speaking from an audience member
perspective not a fan
um where you know there's a lot of
interesting books and you know whether
there'd be about war or not there's a
lot of interesting people whether they
be military people
present past or not
um but I think that what I'd always
really enjoy or learn from both is kind
of your take on all of it where you know
you know colder than hell right cool
good book you know I don't know that I
would read that book just on my own as
if you didn't exist I don't know but
hearing it from you yes of course yes
made it like oh that's interesting and
you know heavy and like all this stuff
but what really what I really was a fan
of was your take on it and the fact that
I could or someone I mean in this case
it's me where I could ask questions to
clarify what do you think about this
element of that or how does this apply
to you or me or whatever like I feel
like that part really has the value of
it
which kind of goes in line with kind of
what you're saying but um
even more than that and Rewind back to
you
um
talking about doing it once a week it
kind of put in my head where you know
how you know in the beginning when we
first started a lot of people a lot of
people without and I really mean it a
lot of people would ask me hey like how
do I start a podcast so much where I put
a page on the website saying this is how
you start a podcast here's all the
equipment or whatever so I didn't have
to you know answer the questions all the
time
um
so let me ask you like how hard is it to
do this podcast like as far as hardness
goes I know this is a very specific
podcast where you got to read and do all
this stuff but like just consider that
maybe wasn't that much work for you but
just I don't know maybe arbitrarily just
sort of think uh generally speaking how
hard is it to do a podcast doing it
versus like seeing it from the outside
what you'd expect it's probably a lot
harder than
it seems like it's gonna be yeah and and
I think the weird thing is especially
now that the that there's so many
different podcasts and
there's look there's millions of
podcasts and maybe
maybe 10 of them are good
yeah right
which which what that means is so let's
say there's a million I think there's
more like more than a million but let's
just say there's a million and 10 of
them are good that means there's a
hundred thousand good podcasts to listen
to and you're not even gonna find them
and so if you're jumping into the
podcasts right now it's gonna be really
difficult to get people to start
listening to your podcast because
they've already got 999
000 other podcasts or sorry they've got
99 000 other podcasts in their download
that they're going to listen to before
you get in the game so
I think now it's really hard because
there's very little return on investment
for having a podcast because the chances
of people listening to it are relatively
small
now if you're doing your podcast because
you want to do it and because you enjoy
talking to people and and you're doing
it for yourself cool I think that's
awesome and I think that's a great way
to go about it that's
that is kind of how we went about it
we happened to get into the game when it
was easier to get into the game
and we got freaking great support from
Tim Ferriss and Joe Rogan
you know giving us some giving us some
props out of the gate which kind of
brought us up to speed real quick very
lucky for that
but
and then we just kind of stayed there
because there wasn't really any other
podcast that was like what we're doing
so yes I think it's harder than it than
it seems I'd say it's like
you know oh I'm gonna be uh
uh stand-up comedian seems real easy not
real easy I'm gonna be uh what else what
else looks easy but it isn't so easy
news anchor I'm gonna be a news anchor I
could do that yeah you just freaking
read something or say something about
the weather about the weather yeah uh I
think even actor yeah yeah acting as big
because people think
but when you see someone that sucks at
acting and occasionally you know someone
that's some kind of star athlete will
get put in a movie Sometimes they pull
it off sure but sometimes they don't
yeah and you oh acting is harder than it
looks
[Laughter]
that's a sad statement but it's true
yeah so I I think maybe podcasting is
like that I think I think Rogan
definitely makes a lot of people think
because he's he's one of those people
that you know when you watch a good
Surfer you're like dude I think I could
you know I think I could do that because
that person's making it look so easy and
Rogan makes it looks real easy because
he's just kind of cruising through these
conversations yeah and then you go oh
you get into a conversation with someone
and it's not going somewhere Joe Rogan
is a black belt at finding a place to
pick it up and maneuver it and listen
and and push back but not too hard and
and give resistance enough that it makes
the person work which gives more
information like he's just a pro and it
seemed because he he's so good at it
that it seems kind of like it might be
pretty easy yeah so you know the hey I'm
just gonna kind of do what Joe Rogan
does is it real uh it's a real Ambush
waiting to happen your ego oh it'll tell
you right here man that is so so true
because like especially if you've been
following him from the beginning where
you know when they started they're on
this like the most rudimentary live
streaming website it's got something
Justin TV they're sort of Justin.tv or
something like this where him and this
guy Red Band Brian they would like in
Eddie Bravo would be in there something
and they're just talking and they're
like you listen to it I'm like why am I
listening to this even though it is kind
of fun to listen to It's just guys
talking trash and having fun making
jokes and stuff so even that then like
even that he had skill in that which is
literally unseen like even him making
like dumb jokes on the fly or whatever
they're kind of funny he's a comedian so
he knows how to do that so and as he
evolved just and it seemed really
natural too where he just got more and
more into the conversational kind of
part of it but at the same time time it
wasn't like this prepared performance
like you might see on TV or something
like this and you know some people they
can do a performance at a play or
something like this and you'd be like oh
he nailed that I don't think I could do
that or a singer or something but a
conversationalist
man it's kind of like the better they
are the less you see on the craft you
know and and to most of us we're like oh
man that'd be the best job ever all I
got to do is nothing basically just be
me and talk to these freaking cool
people or whatever
so yeah like then so when we started
um when you would talk you're like kind
of the same way where you're just
literally the exact same person off the
mic as you are on the mic
but when you get on the mic as a normal
person it's like oh yeah
[Laughter]
you're on the mic now and it's way
different just like how you said the
actors like you know I can act and once
all the cameras are on and everyone's
watching you and the microphones in your
face you're like
like right you don't know what to do
it's like yeah at Echelon front when
we're making like uh videos at Echelon
front for for training for putting out
word
and everyone's joke is like is everyone
knows what they're gonna say and then
the camera hits record and everyone just
goes into brain lock and it takes nine
takes to get a 45 second video
it's too bad that's real you know so
that's like a skill it's one of those
unseen skills you know and it's really
really critical
so
um so that's what I noticed and then
here's when I really noticed it when we
started and then a lot of people that we
know um they come to me and ask me hey I
want to start a podcast and all this
stuff and I'm thinking to myself oh yeah
I know I know how you feel freaking like
when I heard Joe Rogan freaking I wanted
to start a pie like my dream career
would be that right there just sit in my
own house well my basement or some place
that I made up and talked to my friends
and talk to actually just get paid for
that wow this is the best job you kind
of do have your dream job in a way
it's even better because there's no
pressure I can just let you talk you
know
but so I understood but they'd be like
hey what advice do you have or whatever
and that's what I would say and here's
another phenomenon that I would see
where some people some people they
embrace the cameras and all that and
then they act like a different person
it's like all of a sudden they're this
like dramatic expert now you know kind
of like bro
so he doesn't sound right so that and
then um and then the other main thing as
far as advice that I would give and I
still would will give is like you got to
keep doing it
well okay I'm gonna I'm gonna say this
because a lot of the people along the
way that we
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen go
to Jocko underground.com And subscribe
and we're doing this to mitigate our
Reliance on external platforms so we are
not subject to their control and we're
doing it so we can give you more control
more interaction more direct connections
better Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it cost eight
dollars and 18 cents a month and if you
can't afford to support us we can still
support you just email assistance Jocko
underground.com and we'll get you taken
care of until then we
mobilized
Underground